[Musica]
due settimane fa sono tornata da
un'esperienza all'estero di cinque mesi
durante i quali ho frequentato una
scuola superiore a wexford in irlanda il
sistema scolastico irlandese sotto certi
aspetti molto simile a quello
statunitense quella possibilità di
scegliere le proprie materie di studio
io ho optato per delle discipline più
affini all'indirizzo di soli pil italia
scegliendo quindi storia e l'assenza di
greco antico e latino chimica e biologia
infine oltre alle materie obbligatori
come matematiche inglese ho scelto di
studiare and politics and sites politica
e società
incuriosita da questa disciplina assenti
in italia ma senza riporre troppe
speranze pensando che sarebbe stata
molto simile alla nostra educazione
civica in realtà mi sono dovuta
ricredere
le elezioni hanno partecipato sono state
attive coinvolgenti aperte al dibattito
al fondo che desideravano in
terminassero mai il programma che
abbiamo affrontato è stato vastissimo
siamo passati dall analizzare le cause
del gender gap allo studiare in che modo
i media vengono utilizzati come
strumenti di propaganda fino alla
prendere il pensiero di politici
scrittori filosofi di ogni tempo dai più
famosi come locri marx ad alcuni meno
noti e di cui son venuta a conoscenza
solamente durante le elezioni come
silvia volpi professoressa universitaria
di sociologia e autrice di libri sul
patriarcato
sono rimasta affascinata dal modo in cui
docenti e studentesse io frequentava una
scuola completamente femminile si
mettessero sullo stesso piano per
discutere di politica in un modo che non
reputiamo possibile dal momento che non
mi era mai accaduto nei dodici anni
distruzione qui in italia di assistere
ad un dibattito così aperto all'interno
delle mura scolastiche
come conseguenza di questo continuo
scambio l'idea mi sono resa conto che le
mcrae tani e irlandesi fossero molto
spesso più informati di me riguarda vari
aspetti dell'attualità e decisamente più
sicure nell'esprimere la propria
opinione su certe tematiche
questa nuova realtà mi ha dato quindi
modo di lavorare la seguente domanda che
spero anche a voi qui questa sera
perché questa preoccupazione del formale
politicamente i giovani non è presente
allo stesso modo anche nel nostro paese
nel sistema scolastico italiano
l'educazione politica dei giovani viene
messa completamente in secondo piano
è solamente da fissando per esempio che
è stato introdotto l'obbligo delle 33
ore di educazione civica per studenti
delle scuole primarie secondarie e per
esse non è stato comunque per gli sforzi
un programma definito scegliendo di dare
grandissima libertà ai docenti sugli
argomenti da trattare
in questo modo vengono sì latitanti che
però in assenza di un collante una
visione d'insieme perdono valore ed
efficacia
perché proporre di abbassare il limite
di età per votare a 16 anni poi non è
presente nel sistema scolastico italiano
un programma volto all'educazione
politica che faccia capire a me ai miei
coetanei ma anche ragazzi più giovani
cosa voglia dire effettivamente far
parte della vita politica del nostro
paese
nessuno penserebbe mai a consegnare la
patente ad una persona che non ha
dimostrato di saper guidare
correttamente
allora perché viene data la possibilità
anzi diritto e dovere di votare senza
un'adeguata formazione
forse quello precedente un paragone un
po azzardato ma quello di cui mi sono
accorta avremmo veramente bisogno gli
studenti è una bussola uno strumento che
ci aiuti ad orientarci nel labirintico
mondo della politica e quale luogo se
non la scuola agli strumenti adeguati
per offrire un'educazione politica che
sia gratuita oggettiva e soprattutto è
disponibile a tutti
mi sono però anche chiesta quali
potessero essere le difficoltà
dall'introdurre una materia assimila
politics file i nostri piani di storie
mi sono venute quindi in mente tre
possibili argomentazioni
la prima di queste è che al giorno
d'oggi se noi giovani siamo realmente
interessati ad istruirci su un
determinato argomento
possiamo liberamente farlo tramite la
molteplicità di mezzi che i nostri tempi
ci offrono
tuttavia mi sono risposta che votare più
in generale far parte della la politica
non è solamente un nostro diritto ma
anche un nostro dovere ed in quanto tale
lo stato dovrebbe offrire a tutti i
cittadini non solamente a quelli
interessati dei mezzi adeguati la
bussola di cui parlavo prima per
orientarsi in questa realtà complessa
la seconda argomentazione è che bisogna
evitare la propaganda politica delle
scuole
penso però di aver reso chiaro che
quella che bisogna intendere come
educazione politica sia estremamente
lontana dal favorire un ideologia
rispetto ad un'altra
e ovvio che favorendo il confronto di
opinioni e il dibattito e gli studenti
siano spinti a prendere una posizione e
ad elaborare delle argomentazioni a
favore di questo tuttavia ciò non
presuppone necessariamente un qualsiasi
tipo di propaganda
l'ultima argomentazione che forse quella
più utilizzata e che mi è risultata più
difficile da controbattere è la
proverbiale mancanza di tempo della
scuola italiana
c'è sempre questo bisogno di stringere
in un periodo decisamente insufficiente
limitato il maggior numero di argomenti
possibili perché sennò c'è il rischio di
rimanere indietro col programma
quello che mi sento di dire è che è
impossibile trattare nel corso della
scuola secondaria ogni singolo argomento
di ogni singola materia
bisogna attribuire delle priorità
decidere quali aspetti della formazione
di futuri cittadini siano più necessari
a mio parere l'introduzione di questa
materia o penserò una modernizzazione di
educazione civica con degli obiettivi
stabiliti nazionali è un numero maggiore
di ore dedicate porterebbe a moltissimi
benefici
come ho scoperto in irlanda le
possibilità di argomenti da trattare
sono infinite e si riuscirebbe
finalmente a trovare uno spazio da
dedicare a proposte come il quotidiano
in classe che per chi non lo conoscesse
è un progetto che avvicina gli studenti
delle scuole superiori alla lettura e
analisi di articoli di giornale
un altro punto che avrebbe la
possibilità di essere ampliato è lo
studio della storia
critica italiana dal 900 ai giorni
nostri
necessario per andare a votare
consapevolmente
nell'attuale programma di storia infatti
si segue l'ordine cronologico degli
eventi quindi è naturale che ci si
dedichi alla storia contemporanea
solamente nell'ultimo anno di scuola
superiore tuttavia così facendo si
arriva ad offrire un indispensabile
strumento di comprensione della realtà
quando la maggior parte degli studenti
ha già raggiunto la maggiore età e
quindi ipoteticamente potrebbe essere
già andato a votare
ma il contributo maggiore viene
innovazione di questo genere sarebbe
sicuramente la possibilità di avvicinare
i giovani alla politica
il report 2020 dell'istat dichiara
infatti che la mancanza di
partecipazione generale nei confronti
dei temi politici è tristemente in
crescita riguardano circa il 30 per
cento dei giovani tra i 18 ei 34 anni
questo penso sia dovuto in un pensiero
comune che percepisco molto spesso
ovvero che la politica sia un qualcosa
di lontano da noi che non ci riguarda
direttamente
a questo proposito vorrei citarvi una
frase tratta dalla politica di restodel
e l'uovo è persona tour a un animale
politico
gli antichi greci più di duemila anni fa
avevano già capito trovandosi
quotidianamente a discutere dell'agorà
sulle pressioni anche più rilevanti che
la politica è un qualcosa che ci
appartiene per natura perché circonda
ogni aspetto e ogni momento della nostra
vita
politica infatti non ha solamente grandi
decisioni economiche o e tra tanti
dibattiti in diretta televisiva ma molto
più semplicemente ogni discussione che
prevedeva due o più opinioni
contrastanti e le rispettive
argomentazioni
ogni decisione all'interno di un gruppo
più o meno ampio di persone che siano
essi gli abitanti di una stessa casa di
uno stesso quartiere di una stessa città
o di uno stesso stato e politica
politica e quindi tutto ciò su cui la
nostra società moderna infondata ed
essendo noi stessi parte di questa
società come possiamo anche solo pensare
che la politica non ci riguardi
direttamente
grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]